[Music]
saturday of course was st patrick's day
was saturday
or as it's called in los angeles cinco
de mayo for white people
really white people
that's a crazy thing out here in la
saturday here in l.a saturday was saint
patrick's day and sunday was the la
marathon
yeah in other words no irish people ran
the la marathon
we were along the sidelines vomiting
right right
you should have just put a number on it
people would have thought you were
running
big news from the campaign trail you
probably heard about this this is a big
story rick santorum has now said that if
elected president he would ban hardcore
pornography
[Music]
yeah which is why mitt romney just
changed his slogan to mitt romney
because santorum would ban hardcore
pornography
i
look at this
do i know my crowd or what
he would ban hardcore people were like
no
no
that's what i live on it's it's obvious
cinemax has gotten to him yeah
it's ridiculous
if i said he had banned all food and
nutrition you would not have reacted
that anger
water will be outlawed what we can do
without water
pornography
speaking of rick santorum a new racy
photo of a shirtless rick santorum
lounging in a pool is circulating on the
internet
right now yeah ironically uh the photo
has proven to be a very effective form
of birth control
santorum has mixed feelings about
look at that
that's what i do when
i think it's not quite good enough
that's my poker towel
i'm trying to give it a little extra
lift
over the weekend a group of occupy wall
street protesters tried to reoccupy new
york's zuccotti park
yeah and you can tell the movement's
been hurting for funds because this time
they call themselves occupy wall street
brought to you by sony pictures 21 jump
street
a new study shows that i couldn't
believe this a new study shows that 30
million
chinese citizens live in caves
it's true
that's true
live in caves yeah a spokesperson for
these citizens said hey it beats making
ipads
[Applause]
uh over the weekend the creator of red
bull
died at the age of 89.
yeah as per his wishes his funeral will
be an all-nighter followed by a
hellacious midterm
hbo
hpo had to cancel its horse racing
series luck
after the death of three of the horses
yeah however uh hbo executives are
eagerly promoting their next big series
glue
[Applause]
backstage was saying i know is that over
the line i don't know i don't probably
get a laugh i never thought yeah
glue
crazy story in the news a new report
says that not long before osama bin
laden died he really wanted to change al
qaeda's name to help its image he wanted
to change the name al-qaeda to help
their image yeah
unfortunately uh pinkberry was taken
so they
[Applause]
how mad would the people at pinkberry be
another threat from pinkberry no